do have breaking news and at least two
Palestinians have been killed in an
Israeli raid in the occupied West Bank
City of nablis more than 36 have been
injured let's bring in the Ibrahim she's
joining us from Ramallah also in the
occupied West Bank we're just looking at
the the ongoing clashes taking place in
nablis on the live feed Neda tell us
what you've been hearing
we've been hearing that the number of
those who were injured is not only 36
which is a high number but that the
majority of them were hit by live
ammunition this is a very high number
when it comes to the confrontations that
take place between the Israeli forces
and the Palestinians now we know that
nablis is an epicenter anabolism Janine
for armed Palestinian men and we've seen
similar confrontations go on and
exchanges of fire between Palestinian
Fighters and Israeli forces but it is
unusual for those raids Israeli rates to
take place in such a time in the morning
it is 10 a.m when the Israeli forces
raided local time it was a busy market
and we heard that two Palestinian
Fighters were surrounded inside a house
at the outskirts of the old city they're
members of a group that holds itself the
Lion's Den it's a group of armed
Palestinian men who say that Israel only
in the understands the language of force
they've taken up arms they've had a
assumed responsibility for several
attacks against Israeli soldiers and
Israeli settlers in the occupied West
Bank so we are looking at an escalation
we're looking at 52 Palestinians who
were killed since the beginning of the
year by Israeli forces and we're still
in the second month of the year
okay nadat we'll leave it there thank
you so much for that update from the
occupied West Bank